[Music]
the true patriots are back baby that's
right
[Music]
we are back we are here to bring
righteous
truth
and fury
that's right
i'm ready
to these conservative
first 30 seconds i can't curse
you can't curse in the first time nin
can poop nem can poops oh
that hit hard burn that's a burn we have
such a great episode here today
all the usual suspects and more
and a surprise at the top that you
haven't even seen okay that's i'm
excited for this our sponsor today is
harry's razors thank you very much
now um
don jr
has a special wish for us uh oh oh no we
got him on cameo oh how much was this
dan 500 bucks 500 big ones 500 big ones
worth every penny dude
i don't understand how this is worth
this guy's time other than the only
explanation is that he's
not that rich well yeah
i don't think i don't think the trumps
are as rich as they once were well
especially don jr yeah
daddy probably cut off the faucet a
little bit oh for sure yeah
yeah he's just how else is he gonna fund
his uh you know
candy yeah allegedly
just looking so
just so
healthy like he he's always holding a
fart in i don't know how to describe it
like he's just he he's like i re i
really need this shart but i gotta hold
it in because i don't know last time i
farted it turned into something else
it's just so bad
it's just
well don junior has a special wish for
our new show and uh well i hope you
everybody enjoys and especially you
hassan all right let's hear it
the legend himself
ethan
maria tells me that you're a small
business owner about to open a new store
leftovers and i just wanted to give you
guys a shout out of well wishes uh good
luck with all of that i love that that
entrepreneurial spirit still exists
despite obviously some challenging times
but
just plow through
keep going
never give up uh i hope you can live
that incredible american dream and that
entrepreneurship it's absolutely awesome
good luck with all of it we need more
just hard-working patriots like yourself
and in these difficult times and with
the craziness that's surrounding us on a
daily basis i think more and more people
are starting to understand why so good
luck i wish you all the best success in
the world and i look forward to seeing
you guys soon all right
and i think you will be seeing us that's
wishes all right watch this watch this
that awkward that that's like awkward
yeah he's a look down to turn it off
yeah how are you gonna do 500. cameos
right and still not figure out how to
turn it off quickly or cut the video
probably because it's the first one he's
got
no shock
you know this is like you know this is
like classic rich guy you know
republican rich guy bachelor party
antics you know what i mean this is
definitely some [ __ ] that like rich
republicans
oh yeah i'm just kidding
even people are buying from rudy
giuliani like who the [ __ ] would pay
rudy giuliani for money didn't we get
one from rudy dan or we never did uh we
tried i think he actually rejected us oh
no no yeah he's too he's too clever yeah
he's too clever anal sex
yeah
i want to get a moment on this i i i
have to admit i when i ordered this
cameo i was wanting him to say ethan and
hassan and but because it's don jr with
with a middle eastern sounding name he
literally rejected it yeah
yeah that would have tipped him off he i
i'm i'm almo i'm certain he knows uh who
i mean he's like tweeted about me in the
past oh there you go
so what i was thinking is maybe we can
use this as our cold open and maybe he
could even sue us which would be fun
because
i'm already being sued uh sure yeah you
can sue anything brandon your idea of
fun and mine are very different
i'm still used to being sued by now like
me yeah i was gonna say i not fun i feel
like a lawsuit
the first time was very traumatic the
second time is fun to be honest you know
what i i i get that it's kind of like
whenever people are like dude you're
being canceled again like how do you
deal with it like how do you deal with
that dude i don't [ __ ] care like
it's literally just like every week
there's a new thing that people are
upset about well who cares the first
time i got sued i was very broke and the
money was extremely stressful yeah the
second time you know
i'm i'm doing much better financially
and uh
i uh i have no problem being a dude best
thing is guys like this have like the
worst lawyers they have like one lawyer
and he's dying of code
i'm being sued by right now ryan
kavanagh who's apparently a billionaire
and he has the worst [ __ ] lawyers
they literally don't care
yeah i think it's because again like
they just they they have like their own
they're they're just like bad grifters
they're not good at what they do
you know if you went after like peter
thiel that's a whole different story
right i mean like you're done if that
happens i think they're just used to
sending people cease and desist and
threatening litigation and then they go
away because they expect that they have
better lawyers
yeah but uh anyway here's one more
awkward uh a sign off from don junior
best wishes
all right
thanks bro you can turn it off now you
see
you see his yeah you see the light come
off
you know
where's your daddy
yeah so maybe a cold open
anyway um here's the first thing i want
to show you today hassan this came up
across my desk on twitter
someone tagged me in it
this [ __ ] and this video is
still up the ak guy
you know about this guy no i don't know
i do love herrera
he did an ad
on his ak
video promoting a fake mask
okay
here it is let me let me get your take
on this
before i get into it first off it's time
to thank our sponsor who makes stuff
like this possible would you like to
become a thermonuclear weapon at a
nursing home then i can you give us a
little volume
did this guy just say you can kill
people at a nursing home stuff about
this like but before i get into it first
off it's time to thank our sponsor who
makes stuff like this possible would you
like to become a thermonuclear weapon at
a nursing home did this guy just say
you're going to kill people at a nursing
home i think so but there's did you i i
like i don't know the background of this
person but like
he he has to be joking i mean i know
he's joking but like a therapist this
has to be like a like a like a parody of
a parody i don't even know what's going
on here well here i'll just play for you
i'm not gonna pause
don't pause
then i would suggest you check out our
sponsor for today fakemasksusa2.com
it's literally what it sounds like it's
it's a fake mask i have to go to la this
week and i'm not [ __ ] excited about
it
with all the masks nazis on the website
it's gonna be a [ __ ] show but luckily
all i have to do now is whip one of
these bad boys out of my pocket
and i'm good to go it's like active camo
for karen's it's great the best part is
it's completely breathable it's like i'm
not wearing a mask at all it's a great
way to get those kind of people off your
back especially since we're about a year
and a half into two weeks to flatten the
curve i have nothing wrong with you
wearing a mask if you would like to wear
one but me personally i like to be able
to breathe freely without wearing a face
diaper so if that's the sort of thing
that interests you go ahead and click if
you are wearing a face type comment give
them some love for sponsoring the
channel especially since
i'll be honest that product's just
really [ __ ] funny anyhow let's yeah
so what a [ __ ] weirdo dude what's
wrong with it you're still wearing a
[ __ ] mask if you're already putting
the mask on your face why don't you just
wear a real [ __ ] mask how are you
gonna be a big tough guy and be like
yeah a little [ __ ] shooting guns
brother like and then you're like but a
[ __ ] face diaper dude up that kills
me i knew you weren't wearing the face
diaper yeah that is insane imagine being
cucked by [ __ ] liberals like that
that you have to [ __ ] put a fake mask
on dude yeah what's what's next dude
what's going on you you're like you're
really that cooked just don't wear masks
at that point right that's what i'm
saying don't be a little bit
don't be a beta ass [ __ ] just don't
wear a mask [ __ ] it's just it's in
absolutely insane to me that like this
is where we're at because like
i don't know i mean look i i was just at
the gun range this past week and i love
shooting guns i think guns are very fun
they should be heavily regulated of
course because they murder people uh but
um you know don't murder people
yeah of course
you know what murders people fake masks
if you [ __ ] have covet and you put on
a fake mask you go to the [ __ ]
nursing home
so what do you what so what's your take
on that comment you can be a thermo
nuclear weapon in a nursing home like
he's you can be
he's kidding that you could be i know
but that was such a like that was such a
ridiculous start that i was like i mean
he's obviously joking but that was such
a ridiculous joke that i thought the
rest of the content was also like i
thought that that was yeah he was like
making a joke about like how psychotic
conservatives are all right it turns out
no like he's just that's it yeah so i'm
assuming the product is made to look
like a real mask as much as possible and
be made of like super thin mesh that
doesn't isn't protective at all if you
want to check it out i have the link to
their store oh yeah i'm looking at it
right now 100 compliant face masks
and in the first photo two weeks just
definitely check this website out i
wonder if he's got the link in the yeah
fake map [ __ ] is fake mask usa
too yeah and and this is a
oh oh that's hot that's kind of like a
kink like that's that's what i was
saying like that's like my fetish yeah
that is like
i don't know what's going on there dude
like why would you put that on it's so
much more embarrassing to just like not
wear a mask or wear a mask this this is
straight up the most beta [ __ ] i've ever
seen in my life yeah it's always like
when it when you see like conservatives
like wear a mask or like a political
statement on it like uh you know like
they're muzzling us like i'm wearing a
muzzle it's like dude what is wrong with
you
veda
i mean yeah you know right you know be
funny oh this one says the
the uh double mesh fake masks that
protects against covet so it's actually
just a real mask
wait oh my god no uh
but they're like selling a worse product
overall for like eleven dollars oh god
everything is conservatives are so
stupid i'm sorry if you're gonna wear a
fake mask just wear the [ __ ] mask
like it makes it make it it looks like
they're wearing lingerie over their
mouth i mean that's better [ __ ]
i just you know you're that shaming
again
oh there's nothing wrong with
just kidding well i'm assuming that
these guys don't want to walk around in
sexy mesh which is basically what
they're doing
so how do they i i need to see the bar
and drink tab like what's going on there
you know what i mean like we gotta see
oh they got bottle openers
for fake masks like a fake mask bottle
opener oh they've got a 20 to 24 ring oh
my god please click on the uh ethan
you have to click on the bar and drink
tab
up there go up all the way trust
click on burn drink
and then click on bottle openers okay
let's see what these read out the first
bottle opener let's see
titties dude that okay wait i take it
back these guys are alpha
and then
a sasquatch with a big old [ __ ] yeah
anatomically correct sad yo me and my
bros we love thinking about how [ __ ]
fat the sasquatch
dude me my brothers like to get around
with our mesh sexy mask and think about
that big old sashquatch
a little bit of training over you gotta
you gotta put that in there proper
pronouns dude bro guy also this is like
the most like um
technique conversion therapy
conservative closet gay [ __ ] i've ever
seen yeah kitties i love [ __ ]
trick everybody i love boobs uh vagina
is my favorite thing
hell yeah liberal tears brother
it's it's wild
liberal tears i'ma crack open a nice
cool can of liberal tears you you buy
this you buy this [ __ ] dude you are such
a [ __ ] irredeemable you are like you
are never seeing titties okay the the
last time you saw titty was your
mother's titty and that's it okay you're
cut off from the titty
it's so bad wait what's the scan
cancelled these nuts there was cancels
these nuts opener oh oh i missed that um
well how we ever gonna like at this
point you know what i think at this
point they just want to be like they
want like
they want to be cancelled so bad like
they're so desperate like please please
someone pay attention to me and like get
upset at this that's what i thought that
i think this whole thing
and a lot of the con and like a lot of
this like uh
anti-vaxxer thing that we'll get into a
little bit there like people protesting
and food courts and [ __ ] is that they
want to feel oppressed they feel in
their hearts for a long time that
they're the oppressed white minority and
they have this outrage and this
entitlement to that they're they are
being oppressed and so they're so
desperate to find it anywhere they can
yeah
no it's just like there is nothing more
oppressed in the united states of
america than a cis
uh heterosexual white guy who owns an
hvac business okay yeah you don't
understand like these people are being
impressed non-stop nobody's talking
about it it's really it's well the only
people that are talking about are you
know the people the brave folks like uh
tucker carlson talker carlson and the
recent uh recipient of the medal of
honor
rest in peace
uh what was his name
oh oh oh uh rush limbaugh yeah rush
limbaugh true american people dude
that's it that's a guy i celebrate dude
i [ __ ] yeah i honestly how great are
you
how dare you oh dude limbo is such a
piece of [ __ ] it makes me so like when
i'm feeling bad sometimes i think about
how [ __ ] dead rush limbaugh is and it
just immediately brings me up and she's
straight up and people could get mad at
me for saying that i do not care he's a
horrible monster yeah he is like he
literally is the reason if you if you
have parents that uh are are currently
like
you know they they were just like normal
regular mom and dad until like recently
and then over the course of like the
past five years we were like what the
[ __ ] happened like rush limbaugh played
a role in that yeah you know yeah that
guy was great i mean he's rest in peace
to a great one
speaking of which stephen crowder good
but more important friend of the show
actually we need a blackjack oh dude
yeah friend of the show stephen crowder
um
has this i've been wanting to talk about
this i've been waiting to do it with you
yeah these guys are so
openly they're just openly racist ethan
is the 52nd one
there is this gets so much worse
the there's
yeah oh this one by the way
i watched the full one oh so pull that
up then steve this is a short this is an
epic hashtag shorts on his own channel
yeah no i love when um i love when he's
like yo this racism hit different like
we got to cut this [ __ ] out and put it
yeah for sure like we got to take
advantage of the seo this [ __ ] slaps
also overwhelming like majority let me
do my part here i'm so [ __ ] stupid
bro so here he they are losing their
minds over the prospects of a black
james bond oh it's good but more
important is they say we need a black i
have no problem nobody said we need a
black james bond but go on
with a black james bond as long as you
don't yeah you [ __ ] lost jesse i have
no problem with a black james bond which
is why i'm going to talk about it
to be the most openly racist person
you've seen since 1920. dude it's so bad
right no oh what's that but the issue
here what it goes super woke why do you
need a black james bond nobody needs a
black james bond you literally just said
you don't have a problem with it so move
the [ __ ] on this is the issue when
people talk about it it's like you're
injecting race where it doesn't need to
be let me just say this one thing i
think that's what there's one area when
people talk about it black james bond
there is no lack of representation of
black american men in the action hero
wait hold on
first of all there's one thing
that james bond can't be
and that's american that's it okay
why is he saying black american james
he's from black america and no one is
even like bringing up michael b jordan
they're talking about [ __ ]
elvis
dude
yeah suave english dude that's james
bond yeah no he was perfect he said
black america in one area when people
talk about it black james bond
there is no lack of representation of
black american men you [ __ ] dumbass
dude he's like american you know what it
is i think like he's just so horny to be
racist that he like he touched forgotten
he just like he
his brain doesn't have a lot of
operating power so he's just like using
all of it to be like
i'm just gonna come up with the worst
thing i can say here oh here i got the
full version let's watch it dude dude
dude i'm gonna be honest with you it's
like first of all they go on for like 20
minutes
and secondly because like what the [ __ ]
is it is this it yeah yeah yeah it's
like that's i i'm pretty sure there's a
full one
yes
i have no problem
with a black james bond as long as it's
the girl who played precious right no
but the issue he watched it goes super
woke why do you mean
a black james bond this is the issue
when people talk about it's like you're
injecting race where it doesn't need to
be let me just say this one thing
this is one area when people talk about
it black james bond
there is no lack of representation of
black american men in the action heroes
we don't need more black action heroes
yeah there's too many black action
heroes man i'm i'm so mad right now i'm
so mad that there's a the prospect of a
look i'm an unshakeable con uh
conservative
until the moment that there is a black
james bond in which i am shook i am
shook it is unacceptable yeah i'm
shaking if you were to have will smith
at his peak right will smith men in
black independence day and run it
opposite a james bond vehicle on the
same weekend will smith would have
decimated it will smith
dude it's just not fair i mean it's
[ __ ] up that these black superheroes
are just owning the market where's our
good white-blooded yeah we have one here
flooded white god american action heroes
yeah for for a british uh you know
british spy
yeah
bro i bet by the way that's got to be
untrue right there's got to be way more
white action
he goes will smith
i mean there are there are definitely
there are black action heroes which they
will get into oh they will get okay
jamie foxx is an action hero
they're all chatty
the last film he was in was shazam no he
said he's a shaft uh he's talking about
shaft which also is
incredibly outdated reference you're
digging deep there buddy of black maybe
i said shaft was like black exploitation
that wasn't even like a mainstream that
wasn't like a blockbuster yeah that was
not a blockbuster superhero like
[ __ ] you know action heroes richard
rowntree is and will always be the only
chef he will only anybody the only one
yeah
well look i think it makes sense to have
a black james bond i don't i don't have
a problem with it because so wait pause
for a second i got to point something
out here so like you know this is the
peanut gallery i'm a big fan of stephen
crowder i watch him all the time yeah so
like so
i've always said this but i just i'm
gonna repeat it like i feel like amongst
white people there's like uh there's
like a there's like a pecking order of
racism and the more racist you can get
it's like a superpower the more racist
you can get the closer you get to
stephen crowder so like the gremlin
that's sitting next to him
he's racist he's just at the table at
the
exactly like his racism levels are like
off the charts that's why he gets to sit
there right you need to find out why
this guy [ __ ] can't even be racist
enough that's why he's back there he's
batman he's like i don't care about
black james money it could be cool it's
like shut the [ __ ] up
watch me be super racist just wait
that's that's a very interesting
observation yeah well because i actually
have the same thing going on here with
dan
well no i'm not racist enough
yeah that's why i'm here oh yeah oh but
it's you'll see think about the clan
like the grand wizard if you've ever
seen like those interviews and stuff
yeah grant was a crowder yeah like if
you've seen if you've seen interviews
with like uh you know clansmen and stuff
like the grand wizard some like crusty
pasty old dude like why is he leading
the pack because he's the most reason
he's like coming up with the most
creative
yeah they're like damn
that ball right there i never i never
knew that uh
we could make something racist out of
corn on the grill yep that's right that
[ __ ] can make anything racist
yeah this man right here is innovative
with his racism
he found racism in ways i never dreamed
yeah that's like he's just gonna always
be really proud
most innovative yeah of course well
crowder is just like you know he's he's
he's the he's the main guy so yeah
all right um let's let's watch this
through zero
really
yeah yeah like thing okay so that we're
we're getting heated up that's like true
he's like he's warming up dude that's
not like oh black james bond he only
goes to siberia there's no other subplot
that could include a black person trust
me okay the british colonize the entire
[ __ ] planet dog they can go to africa
there's a lot of black people there also
there's black people in the uk which
stephen crowder i don't know if he's
familiar with this there are definitely
black people
yeah and correct me if i'm wrong there
may even be black people in siberia yeah
that's that's also a thing you know
here's another thing like whoa and
crowder's mind this black guy's walking
around siberia whoa what the [ __ ] yeah
you know what's really you know what's
really funny about that too
white james bond goes to africa all the
time yeah like literally all the [ __ ]
time
and that in africa people are seeing the
white james bond be like ah yeah
this guy he's clearly a spy he's white
he's a white guy
yeah steven has a problem with the plot
he said look we it's not that i don't
like black people or black and white it
just it doesn't make sense in the plot
people will never buy a black spot yeah
it's just how are you this bent dude
it's so funny it's just so ridiculous
i'm going to need you to be at the bowl
and ready to meet our contacts at 11 43
and then they're like guys it's 1 30.
so making straight up [ __ ] black
people are late jokes oh yeah well 100
like
how can you [ __ ] still how can you be
doing that in this day and age well the
thing is like up [ __ ] racial
stereotype jokes you can't even break
that show on the road yeah you you could
make like you can make funny jokes about
the prospect of a black james bond
oftentimes they're going to be made by
black people and they're actually going
to be funny when this guy's doing it
right it just comes across like you're
[ __ ] dead okay your your dad who's
like racist yeah you're racist dad who's
just like uh you shouldn't say that like
that's you know not even like funny it's
only funny because they're like yeah
black people are lazy that's why they
think it's funny
oh my god dude i can't believe that
they're just res i mean it's just so
open what's crazy
they're heating up
this their even gets they're getting up
yeah i mean and then this is so well
received on on their of their audience
and it's like
that's the problem here is that
people don't this is just the gateway to
racism and people see this and they
think it's okay to just walk around this
is a room full of white guys joking
about black stereotypes i mean
this is the kind of thing that they
would lose their [ __ ] mind about when
someone else was like oh well white guys
are this way and they would be like
dedicate a whole show
to defending the white race
where is our spot look the the the
script
granted no but i think did you turn my
ferragamos into a phone
what does that mean
uh it's ferragamos the shoes like you
turn my shoes into the phone oh cause
they like sneakers or something because
like
well
he i think he's just basically saying
like uh you know
that that's like a normal one just wait
here stephen crowder will make it really
really good you see how proud they are
i feel like they're so proud that they
found a way to be racist in a way that
can like slip under the radar for them
to get beyond youtube you know what's
funny like i mean i say this all the
time but like this is the long way of
saying the n-word
like thing this is literally like
whenever they whenever they do this it's
like
like they just can't say it they want to
they can't right so they're just like
doing everything else around it right
it's like the zodiac code for the n-word
yeah oh yeah thank you
and my car i can't you you look i can't
see the plate on the car i you know
what's gonna happen with five oh i'll
get pulled over for that [ __ ] i can't do
that [ __ ] dropping spikes and [ __ ] i
ain't no i don't roger more moonrake
[ __ ] and the problem is then
he's i can't believe this bro my man is
spitting dude he he thinks he's like he
thinks he killed that
the last time i saw him do that was when
he was doing like the picking cotton
black guy like black there's no such
thing as black farmers and they didn't
get suspended for that because he's back
to the black shirts called parody
oh parodying a bla of the black race
yeah the african-americans well he is
canadian
you know justin trudeau also oh here you
go uh stephen crowder would make a great
james bond uh
james bond has returned the beautiful
white uh savior stephen crowder as james
bond
uh but he quickly he's got to return
he's got to finish uh complete his
mission before his heart stops ticking
so it's uh it's like i'm against the
clock it's like that jason statham movie
was it crank
yeah crank
he just has to be like more racist
he has to be more racist like his heart
stops if he can't be racist so he's just
gonna like
increase the stakes over and over again
exciting yeah
yeah yeah work on that one cam i want to
see cranks even crowder crank yeah you
don't even have to think about it dude
so um
yeah this is great i mean it's just it's
insane and it's so [ __ ] racist and
also it's so unfunny i mean if you're
gonna be racist at least be funny but
they're just i didn't want to say it but
yes that's precisely what i was also
thinking like
like there is there are jokes you can
make there are definitely edgy jokes
that you can you know do and some of
them will not be well received because
that's just how it is okay but like
that's
the
the worst part about it is obviously the
reason but the second worst part about
it is that it's not even [ __ ] funny
it's just a black stereotype that's
super racist but there's no joke yeah
he's doing like a [ __ ] minstrel show
right and and and this is like why he
should just fake he should just go come
in blackface yeah
stop him from doing that that's what i'm
saying it's like it's wild to me
blackface with crowder because
it's so
it's outdated it's unfunny he's not even
doing a good job it's it's wild yet
almost a million views and i think
universal acclaim from his fans you know
what i think though i think this is more
so about like it's not just the racism
uh because that's like you know it's
whatever it's like super bottom of the
barrel first of all it is a super bottom
of the barrel [ __ ] type of uh it's
hacky yeah right
um
but it's also the reception from
liberals that they're like fantasizing
about i feel like oh the libs are going
to get so mad at this oh it's going to
be so funny and it's such a like
that's such a sad way to live your life
like i never i never operate that way
i'm never like oh i'm gonna do something
and then um i can't wait for the
conservatives to send me death threats
over it like that's such a pathetic
[ __ ] way to live you're so cucked to
liberals you know it's like
it's been like that for a while where
everything they do is just operating on
lib liberal tears and it's amazing how
um that's like all they have yeah i'm
gonna own the libs by doing like you
know black 18th century uh [ __ ] into
18th century racism
what with like you know 1980s
era jokes he's also begging to be banned
on youtube so he can like make a patreon
and [ __ ] do a whole like uh song and
dance about censorship and stuff oh 100
he's gonna take out the the
anti-aircraft guns to put in subwoofers
hit the button yeah like that's what i
mean like black people like listening to
loud music and like you know
you know put subwoofers black james bond
took out the anti-aircraft missiles and
installed subwoofers dude
you know what kind of jokes that is like
that's clint eastwood bro that's like
that's literally like what are you grant
torino like you're the you're you're
[ __ ] like you know 30 whatever years
old okay
why are you making jokes like a grandpa
i'm a little offended that people aren't
talking more about this though because
like if this was like a jewish joke for
example and who was like oh yeah how oh
he's like jewish james bond stumbles
into an oven
i feel like people would be more angry
about that 100 yeah
um but somehow that's this is just cool
to do
i'm sure
yeah it's just jokes people okay this is
the freedom of expression that we that
facts don't care about your feelings
okay uh yes the jew yes millions of jews
were killed in the holocaust but you
know there's nothing we can't joke about
and steven crowder is a great guy yeah
stephen stephen crowder was actually
bringing attention to the holocaust
right spit in my mouth look in my eyes
and he's like is it wednesday
look we didn't say put chris rock in the
roll okay like he's not going to be he's
not salvaged
you're [ __ ] out bro you already said
you never brought problem with black
james one you're [ __ ] out move his
stick move his desk back
yeah he's further back now
my point is here it's they don't have to
be it doesn't have to be in my issue
they say well we need better
representation this is an issue where
it's pretty equal yeah it's pretty equal
i mean look james bond you talking about
fleming you go back to broccoli you go
back to the history it's just it's a
white guy spy spying on white people i
know we we it's white on white spying
that is the limit of james bond get the
black white out oh the white people are
loud at james bond yeah the bad guys are
white the good guys are white
and the story this is literally not true
again james bond goes to africa all the
time
like all the time
to think that uh the british did not uh
you know colonize uh the african nations
in any capacity or have no business
there is uh insane to me yeah i think
it's i think it's worth i think the
defining characteristic of james bond is
not that he's white it's that he's
english
yes that's precisely it and by the way
so like i guess they're they're
referencing idris elvis who i think
would be an amazing james bond and i
think most people were like that sounds
really cool i because people like idris
elba
are normal yeah but then they make it
all about race and then complain that
people are injecting race where it
doesn't belong when everyone was just
like i like that actor oh here we go
speaking of which
um
there here's a great one steven crowder
is kk crank
[Laughter]
the grand wizard
he has to he has to increase the racism
level yeah okay
frank
interesting his heart will literally
stop that's a [ __ ] now that's an ex
that's an adrenaline rush right there
boy yeah
all right um we're actually at break
time
all right so let's go to a break and
we'll move on we have so much great
stuff uh coming up so stay tuned time to
take a short break thank you rudy
thank you to harry's razors have you
looked in the mirror recently like have
you really looked that beard you grow
out over the last year was a hot new
thing for you but hold on
it's hot outside and it's time to tame
that bad boy harry's can help are you
heading back into the office time to get
that fresh clean all business look back
let's harry help here we go if you don't
know harry's it's time you do harry's
was created to be different than other
shaving companies ooh this is slick dan
you've been using this i have shaved my
dome with it feel that i was about to
say are you domed with this yeah oh that
so that must be a serious razor to dumb
it up it's
really good uh genuinely it's like the
best razor i've ever used damn that's a
dome razor right there boys
harry's craft high quality long lasting
blades and durable weighted handles that
make a close comfortable shave quick and
dare we even say dan enjoyable can we
say that
i don't dare okay on youtube i don't
even dare to say that on youtube wow and
because harry insists that you shouldn't
have to choose between a great shave and
a fair price they just give you both
refill blades start as low as two bucks
that's an easy decision and even easier
new harry's customers get their starter
set which includes a five blade razor
weighted handle
a foaming
shave gel with alloy
aloe
metal aloe and a travel cover putting
alloy in the in the razors
it's a 13 value all for three bucks plus
harry's offers a whole range of amazing
face and body care products for men all
delivered at your door come on now
there's never been a better time to try
harry's go to harrys.com
leftovers to get their starter set for
just three bucks it's 100 satisfaction
guaranteed so you got nothing to lose
here folks go to harrys.com leftovers
right now to get this special offer
that's h h-r-a-a-y
nope h-r-h-a-r-r-y-s
dot com slash leftovers you know what i
always say you said hr
oh you know i always wonder like why
they spell it out like make you spell it
out and then now i know i thought even
let me try to get h-a-r-r-y-s
harry's dot com slash leftovers uh this
i just want to give a quick shout out
because this was awesome jimmy kimball
oh no donald kimball shouting out your
tweet oh yeah seriously the italian
phobia bro why do you cut my [ __ ]
name out dude i mean he put my name in
there but then he like literally
like no free clout like you're just
gonna [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] yo i'm so sick of these
late these late night shows are
notoriously stealing content from
youtubers but they why would they blur
your name out that's hey that's why greg
guffield's beating their ass right now
dude this is my man oh man bro greg
would definitely put my uh twitter he
didn't want to be able to kill you yeah
exactly
i think they are worried about people
getting harassed but he thought your
tweet was serious i was like i have like
a million
followers but his staff definitely knew
this was a joke yeah and people online
strongly disagreed with chris pratt
being cast to play super mario they
people went on social media to furiously
demand that an italian actor portray
this offensive italian stereotype
instead
see this is actually what they're
playing into
this stereotype that republicans have
created about these outraged outraged uh
libs yeah but everybody's joking yeah
literally everyone they quote
i'm making a joke about that stereo yeah
so it's actually [ __ ] up that they're
playing into this dumb stereotype
many many tweets
one italian casted to voice the new
mario movie uh chris pratt playing mario
is italia phobia i love that they
blurted out
i love that they blurred my face too
like a little bit and my username like
thanks man
i didn't even notice give me the [ __ ]
clout dog i don't give a [ __ ] okay yeah
bro that's your ip this is your
intellectual property they didn't even
show my they don't even let me flex my
[ __ ] you know like retweets and likes
on there like come on come on i don't
think i'm ever going to yeah so anyway
shout out to jimbo kimball for he took
it seriously too yeah yeah
ladies if your man cares more about
chris pratt or tweeted more about this
than the texas abortion laws
break up with him and then everyone's
like yeah you [ __ ] these woke liberals
were turning against each other yeah
it's like dude you're literally in the
process
of making jokes about that
instead of talking about the texas
abortion ban if you think that like
that's what we have to do literally
meanwhile crowder's like man
yeah
yeah man there's not enough black people
in the super mario world we need more
black you just get being openly racist
he's just ridiculous he's so cool
so youtube fun oh this was a really
interesting update youtube bans
anti-vaxx content outright
youtube is taking down several video
channels associated with high-profile
anti-vaccine activists
uh who experts say are partially
responsible for helping seed the
skepticism that contributed to slowing
vaccine rates so yeah this is pretty
interesting news this is good news
and um
and i think they're the first social
media network to actually just take a a
hard stance on this
yeah this lady who's turned into magneto
for example
uh was removed this is the lady that was
removed right she was saying that she
gained super yeah she had a fairly big
following on youtube this lady
she was [ __ ] a youtuber yeah
talking about how she became magnesium
there's all these like quack doctors
that are anti-vaxxers that had channels
that that's who uh the other people
listed uh that they banned as well so
here here's such beautiful minds that we
there will now be silenced from this
horrible censorship draconian
1984
literally but i'm sure you've seen the
pictures all over the internet of people
who've had these shots and now they're
magnetized and put a key on their
forehead it sticks they can put spoons
and forks all over them and they can
stick because now look at this there's a
metal piece to that there's been people
who've long suspected that there was
some sort of an interface and yet to be
defined in the interview yeah so this is
a great minds yeah it's it's rumored
that if you take too much vaccine you'll
actually shift the uh earth's magnetic
field yeah interesting which is cool as
[ __ ] why wouldn't you want yeah exactly
that's what i thought too i'm kind of
bummed like yeah back in the day they
were just like yeah you'll be you'll
you'll become gay and also autistic and
now it's like you become magneto
like
right the gay and autistic was uh
i've been waiting for both i haven't
gotten any of those things and it's kind
of [ __ ] up to be honest will be like
if you take the vaccine you will turn
black
yeah
uh here doc dr joseph was banned what
was this guy schtick he was the
originator of the false claim the mrna
vaccines after it will alter your
genetic coding turning you into a viral
protein factor that has no switch off
uh he got banned so this guy is uh an
osteopathic uh
doctor so he's like really into holistic
medicine and uh he was one of the main
and the other lady too they were one of
the main like 12 uh i think they called
him like the disinformation 12 or
something
where uh these guys were like
responsible for the lion's share of
misinformation that was like spreading
like wildfire impossible to combat and
of course
he makes his money by selling vitamin c
and you know yeah vitamin d and zinc and
what not on his website
exactly people that's the grift people
who are desperate to believe that this
isn't working or flocking to him
and he he you if you looked at this you
you represented her perfectly we talked
about it last week when you saw
eric feinstein's patreons
shut up this guy gets the same thing he
sells his [ __ ] he gets all these views
people flock to him this guy's making so
much money
from grifting here he says the uh
the world is becoming increasingly aware
of the rampant corruption and media and
rising up against tyrannical governments
and pharmaceutical industry
bro
that are coordinating this assault on
our freedom and civil rights anyone who
asks questions or challenges the heart
cells immediately
censored yadda yadda it took like a year
and a half
yeah that's literally not immediately
bro
so back in june
uh june 11th 2021
the ama
actually uh did a survey conducted a
survey amongst their doctors
and that survey showed that 96 of
doctors were fully vaccinated against
covert 19 and that out of the four
percent that hadn't been vaccinated this
is all the way back in june uh 50 of
those doctors said that they were going
to get the vaccine
okay
so you know
98 of doctors are vaccinated at this
point maybe even higher than propaganda
bro why the [ __ ] are you looking at like
the two percent what the hell's wrong
with you at some point you gotta be like
all right well i mean you can find a
quack in any capacity and that believes
in anything
so why are you rushing to like avoid all
of that information and like hyper
focusing on the two percent it makes no
sense well it's the same thing with
everything people it's the same thing
with climate change
you know uh there's and like
overwhelming consensus like the same 95
and people listen to the five percent
that say it's not happening and they
build a whole [ __ ] think tanks around
it and they're all the quackiest
[ __ ] too if you listen to what
they say like he's selling zinc bro okay
but um
here this genius is he's banned rest in
peace to a great one love that firm
um shout out to his family so anyway i
just i guess i just want to give i just
want to give you a shout out for doing
the right thing here
yeah i mean this is like whenever people
say
uh d-platforming doesn't work it only
makes people uh you know worse it does
it does
jones i mean that [ __ ] like eat
it off the earth yeah exactly like
you are at this point
like do i
do i wish for a future where you know
people can look at this psychotic [ __ ]
and enjoy it like we do
and laugh about it absolutely like i i
hate that like you know we we have to
get to this
last
stance basically this like
uh this band-aid solution where you have
to like cut the t the faucet off
where it's coming out of the the
misinformation where it's coming out of
i hate that but also at the same time
like
we did we just demonstrably
cannot act right like we demonstrably
are just like hyper focusing on the
psychotic stuff the algorithms are
boosting it because it's like you know
uh interesting and uh engaging yeah it's
engaging it's interesting and it's on
overdrive and it's killing people like
99 of people that are dying of covid
are unvaccinated at that point like how
do you still
avoid that
insanely indicative piece of information
i've been seeing a lot of people who are
i've been seeing a lot of this where
they're like
brutal brutally ravaged by kova near
death and still coming back and be like
don't get the [ __ ] vaccine yeah
people are just it's their whole
identity yeah people are straight up
like yeah four four members of my family
died and i'm still not getting i'm not
getting the vaccine i'm proving i'm i'm
proving my loyalty to y'all now come on
now figgy
come on out ain't no vaccine
vaccine for the cattle
here youtube's rule is claims of vaccine
cause chronic side effects such as
cancer diabetes or other banned claims
that vaccine do not reduce risk of
contracting illness banned
claims that vaccine contains substances
that are not on the vaccine ingredient
list such as biological matter from
fetuses
well that one's true actually that one
is true yeah adrenochrome
claims a vaccine contained that claims
that vaccine contains substances or
devices meant to track or identify those
who receive it that one is true actually
too so yeah
claims that vaccines alter a person's
genetic makeup
now you're
saying yeah i gotta be careful
i'm kidding yeah youtube raiders jokes
claims that the mr vaccine causes autism
well that one's definitely true no
okay that's actually so that one
actually is what i talked about last
week uh that's andrew wakefield from
like literally the 90s like and it's
still and it's still going on
because people like latching on
this info yeah
it's crazy to me
before the mrna uh conspiracies people
were talking about vaccine causing
autism yeah and it was immediately
falsified in the uk which has a
significantly higher vaccination rate
than us now even everybody have their
own version of hogs um yeah they they
dealt with it they dealt with that
misinformation and then like i said he
came to america because we love these
con men we love them to texas baby yeah
uh well this one's true this one's for
sure true uh claims that vaccines are
part of a depopulation agenda i mean
that's obviously totally uh claims that
the flu vaccine
causes chronic side effects such as
infertility claims
what dan
giant balls huge well yeah we know that
it causes
testicles to swell up and for wife and
then wives will divorce you from those
big ass [ __ ]
i just hit my balls claims that the hpv
vaccine causes chronic side effects such
as paralysis man these [ __ ] are
on some crazy [ __ ] yeah
there are like incredibly rare side
effects like incredibly rare and also
not even like fully proven side effect
side effects of vaccines that are so
insanely rare
that um making a bigger deal out of it
is is you're just a grifter you're a
shark you don't want people to
you want people to pay attention to you
and you don't care if uh you're
spreading misinformation while you're
doing that deadly misinformation
uh speaking of misinformation so there's
this cartoonist that some of you may
know some of you may not ben garrison oh
yeah he's a
famous conservative political cartoonist
my favorite uh he caught a really bad
case of covet
which is [ __ ] ironic and wonderful i
mean you know wonderful quote unquote
yeah irony can be one it's called karmic
justice
so um he has he and his wife have been
sick for about two weeks with kovid
which they believe they picked up at a
restaurant yeah
can i get my eggs with the side of covid
please
do you mind coughing in my eggs
he and his wife both in their 60s were
drinking beet so he's refusing to get
vaccinated he thinks it's all
conspiracies he's told reporters
he's to treat his alcovet he's taking
ivermectin and various vitamins uh
vitamins including zinc and he's also
gargling
beet juice so that's an interesting new
one they won the nobel prize
yeah ivermectin won the nobel prize yeah
not for covid so doesn't matter you know
what else won a [ __ ] nobel prize
ethan
lobotomies
exactly so
like what the [ __ ] what kind of what
kind of insane thing is that to be like
oh okay well chemotherapy is it i find
that the funniest argument well ivor
mecton won the nobel prize it's like
okay well
i'm not a doctor i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right yeah uh he said he would never get
vaccinated so he's in he's on his death
or he's close to his death bed
um
um
you know and he's gargling beaches but
i'm praying for my favorite cartoonist i
i hope he pulls through so i can i can
get more of this uh juicy content well
so here's some of his uh famous con
cartoons about covet get some horse
sense ivermectin kicking him in the ass
yeah uh medical industrial complex damn
destroying it he's he's taking that
ivermectum right now it hasn't been
helping him too because you know
famously ivor magden is made in bathtubs
by artisanal crafters and not by [ __ ]
merc
yeah exactly very you know
they're they're rooting for the little
guy in this in this situation little
pharmaceutical merck here's a sucker
with a mask saying humans need oxygen to
live
yeah i know it's crazy we've just been
dropping dead with our masks on not
getting enough oxygen yeah
kids rarely get the virus
mass or child abuse okay
do you have kids
child abuse
uh if social distancing works you don't
need a mask um well
i think
both good yeah do you really want to be
a sheeple yes
so here's the thing okay and this is my
like uh this is my approach to it i i
think that it is annoying to constantly
like have to put the mask on but
ultimately
uh especially if you're at the gym i
hate that i wish we had vaccine mandates
exclusively so that you know gyms could
just like fully open up but
um the thing that really frustrates me
is
i feel like if you go out in the real
world and you live in you know like a
communist state like california even you
you put on your mask when you're walking
into the restaurant and then you
immediately take it off okay you sit
down you take it off there's no social
distancing so it's kind of like a silly
dance that we play here right and it's
not even like remotely inconveniencing
and you take it off when you're eating
and you put it back on when you're going
to the bathroom and it's a little silly
thing right and you do it and it's
whatever it doesn't like destroy your
entire evening or afternoon or anything
like that for yourself and
well yeah obviously but if you're living
in a red state you don't wear a mask
ever okay but then you still continue to
complain about mask wearing more than
like actually engaging in the action
yeah and i feel like in the real world
right now people just don't care like
normal people don't really care about
this as much unless they're just
completely [ __ ] brain diseased by
watching
everyone understands the deal
and yeah i mean it's to me it's like
yeah nobody likes wearing a mask but you
just [ __ ] put it on bro don't be such
a [ __ ] they're so [ __ ] they're so
dedicated to being repressed
that's what this is all about they just
want to feel like i'm white and i'm
oppressed and now finally i have proof
and a lot of this though like
these are all like remnants of
a time when like mass squaring was
effectively enforced in blue states for
the most part
and also like actually a necessity
because we did not have a vaccine right
um
if everybody took the vaccine
the covet death rate
would literally diminish like if we
reached herd immunity the covet death
rate
as far as i understand it even with the
delta variant would still be more
effective than the common the vaccine
for influenza the common flu uh which is
efficacy rating swings around 30 to 40
every year you have to roll out a new
one because it's a new strain
and and that's the that's the ridiculous
part about it it's like if you want to
go back to like a normal world which
everybody wants everyone wants that just
get the [ __ ] vaccine so it's not as
deadly and you're not
destroying icu k uh capacities that are
you know they they already know they
just they don't think they they don't
understand they don't it's just so silly
they're like i don't want to wear masks
either their information their
information world uh just frames it so
differently
i mean look at this
[ __ ] don
donald in this world don't donald trump
is don quixote and he's hot that's my
favorite thing he's like they make trump
like he's not some dumpy ass [ __ ] i i
literally donald's eating
i literally think that's more delusional
than anything else well don quixote is a
[ __ ] delusional
senile dude who fights a windmill
because he thinks it's a knight by the
way and he really apt like this actually
this analogy works
because don quixote was delusional so to
portray trump as don quixote
makes trump a delusional senile dude but
and he because he doesn't he literally
doesn't understand and he's fighting
with windmills which is like a fake it's
not like a real
enemy yeah
and it's completely made up so yes this
is actually right on money it's pretty
ironic and odd and he keeps using the
windmill analogy
kent kyoti
fighting big farm and again the windmill
represents a fake threat
in the actual novel and here he keeps
using it this is like
like liberals liberals only read one
book harry potter and conservatives have
only read 1984 which they have they have
horses
but uh and i guarantee they haven't read
them and exactly so now now at least
he's adding to the you know to the
repertoire this is my favorite my friend
you bow to no one
lord of the rings reference oh my god
you he donald trump is the hobbit who
just saved
to be fair
i think he's physically incapable of
bending
have you ever seen that man my friend
you about to know him basically because
you have gout and you're severely
overweight have you seen the way he
stands like it's just it's like a slash
like that man is unbendable right how he
stands like forward i think it's because
his his butt is so
he's got a giant guy i'd slap i would
yeah dude air that up hottest hottest
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] look at that what is that
posture that's what i'm saying
he has it he's like on his tippy toes
that's really interesting i think he
might have uh elevator shoes on
like how do you carry that much weight
lurch because his ass is so fat that
like it literally balances his his upper
body
like he can do things like that he can
do impressive things that no other man
can
maybe tucker i just realized you were
saying tucker carlson might be a barb i
think he's just into fat asses yeah
maybe that's true right
yeah but you bow to no man
uh
this is delusion lamb donkey this is
what i mean like you dude
trump is flubber thinking donald trump
is like a macho sexy like
masculine strong man
significantly more delusional than
thinking ivormectin will save you from
covid i literally i believe this 100
you don't think this is a realistic
portrayal of trump
it's just so it's so strange that this
is like how they see him how they view
him when he's like a new york
you know born with a silver spoon
elitist and he's so petty and so sassy
and those are qualities that are
redeeming in my opinion i love how you
know how much of a petty [ __ ] he is who
loves drama you know what i mean
massive dumps yeah and yet they they
view him as like big macho masculine man
who's owning the libs and he's like he
is the most
definitive
personification
of a
privileged coastal elite yeah there
possibly could be yeah
yeah and also they betray him here as
the wizard of oz which who of course is
a charlatan uh another a con man
they portraying trump as the wizard of
oz uh so that's funny so now you
understand why i don't want ben garrison
to die of covet because well here
trump uh well there's just so many of
them well anyway since he's basically
the [ __ ] third world stepping on the usa
with is a black foot too
god damn wait what's even the me like
what's even though i think this is
probably uh anti-immigration
oh no um he's saying that like you know
america oh here's the border yeah you're
saying america is being ethnically uh
american whites are being ethnically
cleansed got those black sandals on boy
dude can't even afford shoes yeah
probably that's immigrants yeah
with the tattered clothes and everything
it's just so that's pretty bad so anyway
now that um ben garrison is on his
deathbed after refusing to get
vaccinated uh someone made a great
comment comic in his honor yeah so
here's the ghost of herman cain and hell
here's ben all right here's ben garrison
uh the horse doctors are being like
we're they're trying to take care of him
with the ivormect and they're closing
the door on the vaccine here the vaccine
guy uh that that guy who's super popular
on tick tock who just does this oh yeah
what's his name kala kolabi or something
the italian dude yeah
he's with the vaccine just like it's so
[ __ ] good well was gg's at that point
and uh he's closing the door and you've
got tucker uh filling his hand look it's
so good rule number one of of
drug dealing is you can't get high on
your own supply right
these [ __ ] are getting high on
their own supply all the time like you
can't believe the lies that you're
spreading dude then you're gonna [ __ ]
die here's a tag that says ben diagnosis
gullible
xenophobic hack dumb as [ __ ] yeah
so there you have it uh i don't see
wonderful artists on there and that's oh
come on that's just that's black that
that's just slander yeah yeah so best
wishes to ben garrison on his recovery
should we say that we're recording this
on thursday and do very well there's
like a 50 50 chance yeah we're recording
us on thursday so if he does die
rest in peace rest in peace we'll be
doing a vigil a beautiful artist yeah
we'll we'll gone too soon we'll do a
mural and everything and we'll uh yeah
we'll we'll pay homage uh yeah i will
100 make fun of him when he dies if he
dies i'm just letting you guys know yeah
so this is a herman cain award that's
like worth selling
oh yeah
you know he's not some like uh just some
random person so but yeah without
celebrating his death we will be having
a party with pizza yeah
i will be celebrating his death
if he dies um moving on michael flynn
this is like the vaccine mega mega
episode michael flynn says they're
putting vaccine in salad dressing the
former general of the united states army
armed forces
is out here this guy's a famous q anon
general people love his ass this
[ __ ] is straight doing press
saying that they're putting vaccines in
our ranch my friends
he is a legend and correct me if i'm
wrong i'm not a scientist but i don't
think that is a viable means of
delivering vaccine no i wish it was
great yeah you you want to [ __ ]
vaccinate the white population put that
in the ranch white conservatives dude
that's that's right put it in ranch
let's get that in the branch and
barbecue yeehaw i'll take that vaccine
boy
get that in some
get that in my room
yeah you can't deliver vaccine in a body
of ranch uh general flynn sorry i gotta
put you know somebody sent me a thing
this morning where they're talking about
putting the vaccine into salad dressing
salad dressing bro this guy was
literally like a in in the highest uh
echelon of natsac i can't believe it
like a national security advisor not not
only not only was he the national
security adviser but like
this dude was one of the most like well
respected and also and i i can't believe
i'm saying this truth telling like
straight shooter generals
back in the uh obama administration like
he is the main guy in the afghanistan
papers
criticizing the the afghanistan uh like
program that we had where we were just
like trying to train the afghan security
forces and then he's just this complete
like psychotic person now that has lost
his mind
it's scary because you know i mean he
wasn't a good guy back then either but
he was like at least not saying that
[ __ ] facts the ranch is being
vaccinated i don't get it but it just
scares me because you know you expect
people that high up in our military and
government to have like a tighter
screwed on
but like the fact that these are the
people running the show is very
frightening and now we got [ __ ]
generals like maoist milly ew dude
talking about how he reads
who reads dude the [ __ ] i'm making a
facebook post by general what you
reading the quran yeah come on right
i gotta put you know somebody sent me a
thing this morning where they're talking
about putting the vaccine into salad
dressing or salads have you seen this
yes have you seen this i mean it's and
i'm thinking to myself
this is the bizarro world right it sure
is the bizarre world so there's the
seriousness of what this what this
professional realized he was doing wrong
and he and he's now you know he's found
a new way and then there's the
professional dumping ranch like the
professional dumping the vaccines in the
ranch that's what he realized he was
doing something wrong
i don't know what he's referring to but
i love how he goes we're in the bizarre
world now it's like yes yeah you are you
literally you literally just recognized
on the other extreme that people are i
mean these people are seriously thinking
about how to impose their will on us uh
in our society and it's you that's how
we he's like damn
they finally figured it out put it in
our range we can't resist it yeah it's
messed up with my ranch on everything by
the way he's got general flynn merch so
shout out to the general flynn store
yeah i wonder if he has fake masks for
sale on his uh merch probably
do you see how many bracelets he had on
yeah that i did and you know there's
nothing the more bracelets let me see
yeah okay you're pretty good he's he
doesn't want to do any bracelets
probably no no you can make fun of
braces all the time but this guy's got
like 10 breaks no he's he's looking like
a like a venice beach like you know old
tech entrepreneur guy right now is going
to tell you about how you need to
breathe into your ball sack
you know you know
these are probably one of those like
magnetized he's looking good he's
looking kind of hot general flynn he's
headed up he's got his own merch she's
branded as the turkish delegation on
this podcast i'm
incredibly disappointed that he never uh
kidnapped fito loculan for the 500 000
that the erdogan administration was
offering him but you know what are you
gonna do
that's an insane story we won't get into
that yeah i wanna i'm carrying he's
gonna put him in a [ __ ] like little
little sack and like just kidnap him
with his son
he didn't when he was the national
security advisor
that's what he was doing oh getting
bribes from the turkish government
to kidnap a cia asset that's what you do
when you're uh general those are the
kind of good old site that's a side
hustle that's right sigma grind set baby
yeah exactly yeah so snopes looked into
the claim that they're putting vaccine
in the ranch covid19 vaccine is not
being put into salad dressing nor is
anyone proposed such a thing however
similar mrna vaccines could be grown in
edible plants like lettuce that is
something that is now being actively
researched interesting that's right oh
there it is putting it into our lettuce
those [ __ ] don't eat lettuce
yeah that's right you got to put it in
yeah you got to put it in the ranch so
yeah exactly a few days before flynn
made this comment university of
california riverside published a news
release
uh about a research program that was
attempting to turn edible plants like
lettuce into mrna vaccine factories
so that's quite a [ __ ] stretch to
to put uh
they're trying they're doing research
oh oh there it is let's go to charity
fauci's own ranch i would be very very
skeptical of that yeah what does it say
on the bottom there dan with the syringe
uh
no
colors are from an artificial source you
know what it sounds like it sounds like
he's jerked off into that
like something he's done oh yeah no
i feel like liberals well fauci is such
an antibody factory his jizz actually
vaccinates yeah so
yeah i'm lining up for that and people
were people were talking about how
hottie is uh alongside uh cuomo for a
while so i i wouldn't i could see some
liberals purchasing that
with this jizz hell yeah yeah i do it
with everyone
and i'll call them all rest in peace to
a great one huh yeah can i pee really
quick yeah i should have peed in the
break i've just like been holding it in
go for it i'll wait trending with ranch
so we love that i love it oh yeah
legalize ranch
that's true legalizing it so okay moving
on to everybody's favorite segment hog
of the week
hey you recognize that hog there oh hell
yeah your favorite one of the best hogs
around
uh damn you guys didn't have to you
could at least kept the beanie on you
know what i'm saying we did them dirty
with them
you can't even recognize them without
the baby
that is of course tim poole the most
notorious grifter one of the most
notorious grifters for sure on youtube
oh yeah uh famously called me a flaming
turd bag bag of flaming turds
and uh very disappointed in you yeah
he's he is he
used her you know flaming turd bag
yeah so he this is what he tweeted out
yesterday
he said
first it was the mask mandates
then it was the ma vaccine mandates what
comes after vaccine mandates do you know
what does
kovid ending yeah
devastating that would be that would be
terrible
yeah it's like what is so what does he
think like uh internment camps or
something uh yeah i got them pretty good
i want to give myself a shout out yeah
covered ending got it you did you did
get them wrecked [ __ ] and i'm gonna get
pissed off about it yeah i know you are
big mad yeah so these this is the big
brain conservatives that just uh you'll
find on on youtube he's itching for so
that's 49 state landslide trump victory
tim poole i know i mean maybe even 50.
yeah astute political analysis
so tim paul has been going on and on
about uh how basically the vaccine
mandates rolling out are going to result
in civil war for example he needs to get
he's salivating so he always says this
is like one stick everything is civil
war everything's the war pool we should
call it he constantly is like saying you
know um the blm protests are actually
going to turn into civil war at this
point folks it's like no
it's no
but it's he fantasizing about
armed conflict between americans i mean
he he wants it well because he's
tailoring it to his hog audience that
for some weird reason still thinks he's
like a liberal or something i don't know
so yeah him like dave rubin have this
same schtick where they're like
disaffected liberals well and dave
actually gave up on it like that which
is foolish he he like dave now says like
you know i'm a libertarian i'm a
libertarian and it's like
well you kind of [ __ ] up because like
tim at least still maintains that like i
used to work advice so of course yeah i
myself am
a liberal i'm a progressive i'm more
liberal than most people i know yeah i'm
more liberal than most people i know get
your friends dog
yeah so here he is salivating for the
civil war he says get ready and he
quotes the 3.5 trillion stimulus or the
uh build back better thing coming out
here hopefully the biden administration
has included a vaccine enforcement
mechanism in the 3.5 trillion
uh for 2 000 page build back better bill
which will enable the government to
enforce fines on employers whose
employees do not get vaccinated so he's
saying there's a forced vaccine mandate
coming war is coming
uh the problem with uh with this whole
argument
here's some of some of the replies just
to show you guys just how [ __ ] amped
up this he's he's ready to just start
handing out guns at this point
uh this will lead to bloodshed said the
uh insightful mark lob lobliner
uh haha civil war here we come that's
the best case scenario uh being from
south carolina i'm truly ready for
secession oh yeah yeah you guys will be
good you guys will be way better off
that went great last time
yeah
unfortunately will not happen no real
patriots left to fight yeah cause
they're all dead from covet
we're losing all of our great patriots
yeah yeah yeah hey quick take that acro
ever mektin
told you this ends with revolution or
enslavement i don't see them stopping
now the man
madness is used
to justify further madness the problem
with temple
is that he's a [ __ ] liar
he lies about everything
to fulfill his weird fantasy of a civil
war the problem
with his argument
is that
the provision
tells employers of huge companies they
need to force their employees to get
vaccinated or
test them weekly for kova 19. that's i'm
pretty sure that was
that's the same as slavery i think yeah
that's how that works yeah right that is
basically i'm sorry i'm gonna get pissed
off about that but that's the thing he
says they're forcing everyone to get
vaccinated they're not they're testing
vaccinating or they have to pay to test
which by the way they should that makes
sense they should force everyone to get
vaccinated right but unless they have
like a serious uh you know medical
condition or allergies
they should be forced to get vaccinated
i'm i'm full-blown in support of vaccine
mandates i don't know
i mean america will never be able to do
it because you know everyone hates
federalism i don't i don't know that i
don't know if i'm in favor of full-blown
vaccine mandate because
at the end of the day i think what i'm
in favor of is making it so inconvenient
for people that don't want to get
vaccinated that they're kind of like
have to make
but i i like the idea of forcing the
companies to get make them get covet 19
tests on a weekly basis and they're
going to be forced to be like this is
just [ __ ] inconvenient i'm going to
get vaccinated yeah he's missing that's
what i mean when i say like he's [ __ ]
lying when i say vaccine mandates that's
precisely what i mean as well like for
federal travel you enforce vaccine
mandates not through like private
companies not through like a patchwork
system which is of course the only way
we can ever enact anything nowadays
which is
really sad in my opinion um but uh do it
through a you know travel mandate or you
need to have a vaccine
or or at least like a passport a vaccine
passport to travel
um i think it's the smart thing to do
yeah travel makes sense to me and
federal convenience to me yeah that's
how you get inconvenienced enough that
you're like yeah i'm gonna go get it
even if i don't want to and you see a
lot of people doing that i mean i again
i i don't have a problem with like
individual airlines they should decide
if they want to do vax mandate because
like i would way rather fly with
an airline that enforces
uh that you have to be vaccinated to fly
yeah i want to have like maga airline
where everyone goes and gets coveted and
god bless them but the problem there is
like there's still going to be employees
there you know what i mean and and
they're not going to be protected
they're going to be surrounded by people
and they they're just like i don't have
any other option i'm working at this
mega airlines you know what i mean yeah
i have no problem actually i have no
problem just saying for for air travel
because
you know that's regulated there's a
there's like a
a a regulatory body that governs that
schools should mandate it as they have
and as they will the military should do
it as they have and as they are
and uh same with air travel as well
these are ways that you inconvenience
people to a degree where it's like yeah
i'm going to go out and get it
especially because it's safe and
effective i can drive then dude yeah um
and and big events as well right and
lollapalooza was like
from what i understand
basically a success story which we
didn't really even talk about i mean you
saw those videos people are [ __ ]
crammed together 150
150 new cases vax only or same day uh uh
pcr tests like same day uh negative
covid uh test oh that's interesting so
they didn't even they didn't even do a
full-blown uh interesting yeah but most
people that traveled and went to it were
vaccinated that's 150 new cases only
from that massive thing that's awesome
um so i think college campuses are kind
of enforcing similar things as well
and it's good it's an effective way to
stop people from getting coveted and
and uh you know getting hospitalized
so i'm in favor of it i've been in favor
of it and i will continue to be in favor
of it i think public safety measures
will have a little bit of authoritarian
uh authoritarian authoritarianism baked
into it but that's just how it is that's
everything that the government regulates
is technically authoritarian if you want
to do murder you can't because the
government is excluding you in an
authoritarian capacity by saying you're
going to go to jail if you do a murder
and i'm going to get pissed off about it
you see what i'm saying but the truth is
i think is that he's [ __ ] lying like
he's what he's putting forth is if you
are private citizen working for a
private company you can't even get a job
unless you get vaccinated which is not
[ __ ] true president joe biden's new
vaccine mandate for large businesses is
a strange one and in it that it does not
actually make vaccine mandates for
roughly 80 million americans it's aimed
at talk plainly in the rules as a
singular and obvious opt out unlike
federal employees and contractors those
in the private sector can test for
coronavirus on an at least weekly basis
there so you've there got it but and
they did it through osha right
interesting and and that is precisely
why it's like
incredibly constitutionally protected
like
they did it through osha and that's a
it's a workplace safety requirement yeah
and it makes total sense osha on the
other hand is of course severely
underfunded you're never going to see an
inspector
people that work in uh in
you know any any kind of industry
probably have never even seen an osha
person um i hope they implement like a
like a snitching system because it's a
14 000 fine right if your employer
does not enforce the vaccine mandates
and uh or you know regular testing
weekly testing
and
or and this is the really important part
uh if they don't give you time off
if you do end up getting the vaccine
because that's that's like a yeah
because if you're not getting
compensated and you need the [ __ ]
money you're going to go to work yes you
have to decide between feeding yourself
or you know and that's the that's the
wild part of this that we actually don't
ever really consider or think about is
that
outside of these like vocal uh hogs that
are running around being like i'm not
going to get vaccinated [ __ ] you i don't
want to get cancer or whatever there's
actually a significant chunk of hesitant
people that are hesitant because
the vaccine is free
but it's still not technically free to
get the vaccine especially if you have
to take time off your day to work if
you're working non-stop
and also are worried about like the
amount of time that you need to take off
when you get the vaccine because you're
gonna you might have some side effects
yeah and lastly access the public
transit that you can go to a place where
there are uh vaccines if you don't have
your own car which you know many of
these rural states yeah it's true uh
there's horrible public transportation
so we have completely forgotten about
those people uh i don't think the joe
biden administration anymore is doing
like enough to reach out to those people
that would still get vaccinated the osha
provision you know factors that in so
that's a good thing
i agree with that but like public
transit should still be
uh a a
important way
to to allow people to go out and be able
to get the vaccine if they can't uh
instead of relegating that
responsibility to like uber and lyft to
offer free rides you know what i'm
saying wait they do that yeah uber and
lyft were offering free rides for a
little bit i don't know if they're still
doing it but like pretty cool but like
that's that's what i mean like private
corporations should not
do this uh
functionally out of the kindness of
their hearts like this is something the
government should be doing for sure
supposed to take care of you
well tim poole went to his show to rant
about civil war and about how you have
you're being forced to get vaccine even
though he's a [ __ ] liar
here he is
the legendary
there are many things tucked away in the
democrats 3.5 trillion dollar spending
bill one of the things tucked away
inside it is a vaccine mandate
enforcement mechanism they could fine
you seventy thousand dollars or maybe
even seven hundred thousand dollars
about like microsoft not [ __ ] you
yeah well he's talking to small business
owners i guess small business with a
hundred plus employees yeah it's 200
plus
employees it's 100 100
that's a big [ __ ] company if you have
100 employees and date vaccines at your
business
there's a bunch of other things in there
and this is typical of how our
government has been working for some
time
and that proves to me the republic is
broken it's it's it's gone i'm sorry
you're a [ __ ] liar bro you're lying
you are such a [ __ ] liar he's gone
dude it's gone our republic is gone
the frogs are taking over
yeah
now mine you can buy a cova vaccine it
comes with uh
it's made with the finest distilled
water asbestoside uh uh sawdust and uh
ant droppings
suck at a ding dong
if you put it right in your ranch
dressing and you're good to go executive
branch of the government is mandating
things just ramming them through there's
no legislative process there's no
there's no separation of powers
then there's no republic this may be one
of the most egregious actions i've ever
seen in my life
seven hundred thousand dollar fines for
willful violations of the government's
willful violations that's literally like
first of all impossible to prove and
second of all that means that you have
to be like there has to be written proof
of you being like [ __ ] the government i
ain't enforcing this [ __ ] hell no
i mean here's the here's the reality and
this is why it's great that they're
doing it through osha
if your workplace is unsafe and you're
violating osha restrictions
then you're literally putting your
workers at risk and uh yeah you are
gonna have to [ __ ] pay a fine for
that so like if you have this kind of
energy towards the vaccine like
you know get upset at hard hats and also
our republic is falling apart they're
making us wear hard hats yeah
come on now
yeah and also he's [ __ ] lying because
it's not forcing anyone to vaccinate
vaccinate only test a per week and if
you have a problem with that you're just
a [ __ ] idiot
yeah edict but you know what
it'll go through congress and the courts
have no ability to enforce anything
against it anyway even if they said it
was unconstitutional you're a liar bro
so here we go what happens in 2022 when
republicans sweep sure we see a flipping
back and forth with presidents and
liberal by the way it happens liberal
tim tim yeah he's a he's a liberal he's
very very
most people i know yeah
you know he wears a beanie
what
to hide so his brain doesn't get exposed
to the air i don't know yeah
his dome
he's wrinkly he's got a lot of wrinkles
for sure definitely a big brain on that
one
right what happens when one side just
refuses to accept it it makes no sense
for republicans to legislate democrats
cities and states and it makes no sense
for democrats to legislate republican
cities and states
all we do now is say the federal
government should mandate you do
something how about this
how about you leave me alone i leave you
alone if new york wants to have mandates
then go ahead fine the federal
government [ __ ] we have federal laws
yeah thank god like this isn't that's
how it works bro yeah it it's it's so
it's so insane we outlaw abortion and
you say we gotta get that and you lea we
do us and you do you it's it's wild um
because i mean first of all there's more
republicans in this state of california
than there are in like
you know five other republican states
combined
so let's not forget that there are six
to eight million republicans living in
the state of california yeah so
you know we are technically owning them
by
enforcing rules on them part of the
reason and there are liberals in states
like texas so listen out here in texas
we do what we want black people can't
use the same water fountain i mean yeah
exactly would you mind your own business
over there which is precisely why there
needs to be federalism in this situation
federal [ __ ] laws for a reason
[ __ ] yeah and this is a public safety
he believes that too he just he's
inconsistent it's like yeah you think
guns should be everyone should have
access to guns if california outlawed
guns would you really say you do you and
we do us no of course not no same with
abortion well maybe not in pool but most
republicans are doing their very best to
to completely eviscerate roe v wade um
and seeing some success in texas so it's
all
that part is just
everybody knows he's a liar he's a
hypocrite everyone does it at least i'm
honest when i'm like i want vaccine
mandates like i say it all the time i'm
i'm a big fan um
it's just but like i said every single
federal regulation
could be criticized in this exact same
capacity
all the way down to like seat belt
mandates in cars which again also was uh
enforced through a patchwork mechanism
where lost our republic then boys were
the government making car manufacturers
to put seatbelts in yeah i remember uh
rather than and when it happened it was
very unpopular and now everybody [ __ ]
nobody got problem with seat belts
because we have
you're nailing it we have the we have a
profound ability to adapt
and uh and totally forget about all this
[ __ ] and your republicans will like make
a big stink about it make a big fuss
about it and then ultimately shut the
[ __ ] up because they recognize that it's
it's working and or they lose the fight
or they are unable to grift from it
because it's old news then they move on
to the next thing exactly what what
happened no no more antifa no more
critical race theory and there's no more
uh caravans yeah no more immigrant
caravans and stuff like that because
they're this is the new thing that like
they want you to get upset at and they
want you to hyper focus on
except uh you know once again good
public health measure overall
let's see what else you got but that's
not what's happening
they are just deciding that it doesn't
matter where you live in this country
there is no republic and as much as
people want to say tim don't be so
pessimistic guys plea please friends
when one side
is fighting over control of the
centralized federal government to
enforce their will on other states no
matter if it's red or federal law bro
there is no republic that's the
definition of federal law why are you so
mad about people breaking the law
sometimes there are laws that are broken
and it helps notably like slavery for
instance in order to end slavery there
needed to be widespread sentiment
challenging the law it was illegal and
freeing slaves
those people were criminals just like uh
just like the vaccine
it's like mass
it's so stupid these guys are
complaining about like uh federalism and
whatnot as though they're like uh in
favor of smaller government we just want
to break apart we just want states dick
cheney bill barr
george w bush most of these republicans
operate on unitary executive theory
and they have greatly expanded on the
executive power which barack obama took
advantage of when he murdered an
american citizen with a drone strike in
an extrajudicial drone strike by the way
um but
uh what shout out yeah shout out to you
know drone king uh barack obama but
you know that's that's like
it's ridiculous to act like
either of these like uh parties
genuinely hold like an ideological value
that that revolves around freedom or
whatever and guess what uh these sorts
of vaccine mandates ultimately these
public health measures they offer you
extra freedom when you [ __ ] get the
vaccine and you don't have to wear a
mask anymore or have to cry about it any
[ __ ] more if that's what you like
doing with your friends on the weekend
um you know what's you know freedom
doesn't mean anything if you're [ __ ]
dead if you have a vent in your throat
and you're dying alone scared and your
family members can only look at you from
the other side of that [ __ ] glass
window
in this like overcrowded hospital system
then what kind of freedom you have you
have no freedom doesn't matter i mean
this argument is as ancient as america
itself i mean think back george
washington himself the first president
the father of america had a vaccine
mandate during the [ __ ] revolutionary
war
i mean it it it we used to forcibly
inoculate people in new york for
smallpox
cars would literally go into buildings
and like sit people down and you know
handcuff them and forcibly inoculate
them because there's anti-vaxxers back
then too you know what and and nobody's
complaining about smallpox not being
here killing their [ __ ] kids yeah you
know i don't hear tim poole mourning uh
the fact that smallpox
you know i know he's not married or will
never find a relationship or start a
family because of feminism yeah but but
but like if he did if that was on the
table for him he wouldn't be complaining
about smallpox being gone we're almost
done now you just spoke it into
existence no conservatives pro smallpox
yeah like right next to pro coven
i'm going to a smallpox party to get
that natural immunization yeah woohoo
isn't that crazy
well
what's going to happen when the
authoritarians
want a system similar to slavery and
there is nothing you can do to speak out
against it
why are you dissenting we're saying
we're sending the anti-vaxxers to the
work camp boys yeah round them up
and there's a norway livescope 19
restrictions moved to highest travel
warning level by cdc right he's like
about to pull that up to like complain
about that
you know interesting thing about norway
of course is that um
the amount of total doses administered
or one dose administered at least
is at seventy seven point eight percent
in norway okay since they got the
vaccine which they got later than we did
of course
um they're at 77 and their fully
vaccinated population is at 68.1 percent
for the united states of course well
that number is a little bit lower at
least one dose is uh in the united
states the at least one dose number is
at 64
fully vaccinated at 56 percent so half
of our country is like not fully
vaccinated and refusing to get it and
it's it's is insane to me so yeah norway
gets to have fun which by the way this
will probably backfire on them too
that's what usually ends up happening
whenever you uh whenever you you know
take your hands off the reins a little
bit uh you immediately start seeing
additional covet cases and a big spike
right
but of course tim will never cover that
secondary side effect yeah yeah it's all
cherry-picked sure social credit score
goes down better keep your mouth shut
and fall in line
eventually people are going to lose
their mind i'm going to [ __ ]
i want to work i want to handcuff this
[ __ ] to a chair and force a
vaccine in his arm by the way he's
definitely vaccinated oh yeah tim pool
is definitely right yeah yeah is it like
business is being fined upwards of seven
hundred thousand dollars what's what
what business can handle that
companies with over a hundred employees
you [ __ ] [ __ ] also here you know
how babies you can handle that just just
get [ __ ] vaccinated and test people
yeah there you go like like that's it
right you're definitely having revenues
over 700k but your profit margin
15 20 maybe if you're lucky yeah
and then they say we're finding you and
then your business is shut down and all
those people lose their jobs yeah that
doesn't happen
that won't happen
that will happen zero times that
literally happens that will happen zero
times yeah so temp will out
here it's not waiting for the civil war
shout out to tim's civil war pool hog of
the week congratulations
you know flaming turd bag
the reason why it won't happen is
because you know
it's like these guys they just they just
want to go to the [ __ ] applebee's
they want to go to the food court they
want to go to the mall
they want to yell at the mall at like
minimum wage employees there to be like
your gestapo enforcing this like
unconstitutional rule on me you're
violating my hipaa rights whatever the
[ __ ] they think is like going on and
that's it at the at the end of the day
like that's all they care about is just
like
having a little fun with the boys by
[ __ ] screaming at
you know 17 year olds working at the
mall
one last video to play us out
our favorite margarine taylor gross yeah
wow
that's a good one thank you
she's like mark oh [ __ ] we [ __ ] yeah
you got to do the magic one yeah there
you go
nailed it oh yeah so here we go
she she literally took memes out to
congress we love that for her scooby-doo
memes they're all doing it now this is
like the news fantastic bro who i want
to know who's their printer they got
these really nice high quality yeah
there's someone in dc who's making a
killing on printing memes simple means
let's see who's really under the new
green deal is very real
surprise
is serves china and china only a real
meme
free damn it free
preschool
is serving china's interests
you know what's funny about that is like
i mean she's right china is kind of
kicking our ass when it comes to
infrastructure spending china is
absolutely kicking our ass when it comes
to covert recovery china is kicking our
ass when it comes to china is like
literal night china is 1984. those
[ __ ] oh yeah scary as [ __ ] no
their their their free speech
restrictions are absolutely ridiculous
well they have the social credit scores
where they they scan your face now and
[ __ ] so here's the thing about that
though
um and i do believe that that's
draconian ridiculous authoritarian i'm
not a fan of that uh what's going on
with uh uger
muslims in xinjiang is ridiculous i mean
but like americans complain about social
credit scores all the time
and
then they just
refuse to recognize that we have a
credit system as well yeah but no the
credit system they have isn't you're
talking about like credit yeah i'm
talking about you okay
which is a horrible system granted but
the chinese system if you are taking
place in activism or [ __ ] uh
dissenting or doing protests they will
[ __ ] they will restrict your access to
public transportation and [ __ ] like that
well you don't leave the country they
cut your act this is the funny part they
cut your access to high-speed rail if
your if your credit score is is too low
your credit score is too low
well you know we don't have high speed
rails
so we've
already cut it we already don't have it
we have a credit score and no height
speed rail no matter how [ __ ]
good you are no matter how much of a
good boy you are
right that's a fair point yeah
so like number one
obviously like look i i have the
capacity to live wherever the [ __ ] i
want i could live in china if i wanted
to i choose to live here in america you
know what i mean because i do appreciate
the free speech i do appreciate the
liberties that i have and i also love
like relentless commodity consumption
i'm a hog myself in that respect
i like shooting guns you know all that
sort of stuff
uh but ultimately like
yeah the green new deal is china okay
well that's kind of like
the green new deal is is a great outline
for uh
turning
uh
otherwise like anti-capitalist measures
into a pro-capitalist bill like these
people should love it it's a jobs
program because you can't just be like
we need to restrict energy production uh
you have to also then add additional
opportunities for people to you know
retrain and work in the green energy
sector you sound like a communist it's
great it's a it's a wonderful thing you
know if that's communism then [ __ ]
why don't we have it i wish we did
including free healthcare so today
talking about the green new deal and the
all-out
on the men and women this is a simple
meme oh man that's like me was even
better dude
posted
i owned joe biden and now i own
afghanistan
nice well anyway
that's our episode for the week hope you
guys enjoyed so much more great stuff to
get to but unfortunately there's just
not enough time to get to all the hogs
and whining and crying and [ __ ] and
pissing too much it's jam packed they
give us too much content to do it like
once a week we got tim pool we got
crowder
that was good oh yeah the only thing
we're missing is dave rubin we gotta
find some good dave rubin content for
next week because that guy's a [ __ ]
piece of work too oh yeah we got an
intro from uh don jr i mean friends of
the show now don jr
it's my favorite
shout out to the leftovers from don
jr himself you know we should edit it up
dan so it's like shout out to the
leftovers just do like a edit and we can
do a cold open with let's go
i love you guys
all right have fun great episode first
episode did great yeah i'm happy
leftovers i hope people are you know not
too worried that i don't i don't know
what you're doing on your other podcast
but like i know that people were like oh
my god it's good politics like you got
to get politics out of your
you gotta get politics out of your video
games and also your podcast ethan well i
would this is a politics podcast nobody
was complaining about it i think what i
think what works is that it's just
reaction content like even politics
aside these are just [ __ ] this [ __ ]
is great regardless yeah
so i don't think it's fun yeah i mean i
i do it all the time i enjoy it so
all right all right patriot
thanks for watching everybody this is
hassan [ __ ]
the uh
bringing righteousness to america and
the form of uh
we're put we're gonna be getting uh man
we should you know be fun if we made our
own ranch dressing
yeah like covered covered vaccine ranch
ranch dressing i'm not a big fan of
range i'm i'm a blue cheese boy myself
ugh [ __ ] you're not a people i love i
love it i think blue cheese is the only
thing you put on a buffalo
all right guys thank you so much we will
see you next time tata
oh
10 million dollar set
[Music]
you